PENG YING: Hi Welcome to
Google Developers Live.
My name is Peng Ying, and with
me today is my colleague, Maru.
MARU AHUES: Hey Peng.
PENG YING: Hey Maru.
We're here to talk to you today
about Google Wallet platforms.
Specifically we're talking
about Wallet Objects
and the QuickStart Tutorials.
The QuickStarts are a great
way to hit the ground running
when you start integration.
What they do is showcase
and provide examples
about how to code
against our APIs.
Within it, you'll find
samples to create a class,
to create an object,
to insert the object
using Save to Wallet,
and to leverage
our web service APIs, which
allow your users to find
the loyalty programs and objects
from within the Google Wallet
app.
So specifically
today we're going
to be focusing on the Java
Wallet Objects QuickStart
and how to get it up
and running with Maven.
To show you the
process, here is Maru.
MARU AHUES: Thanks, Peng.
So the first thing we'll do
is go into our documentation.
So go to
developers.google.com/wallet/objects,
and from there click
on QuickStart samples,
and you'll see the five
QuickStarts that we have right
now.
Then click on Java.
Once you get there, you'll
see the instructions
on how to get your
credentials, and to be
able to access the API.
So go read the instructions
from the documentation.
And also you can
watch another video
that we have that
explains this in detail.
And once you have
that, then we'll
go ahead and start downloading
the QuickStart code
and installing it.
So what we are going to
assume that you already
have your credentials,
and we're going
to go now and download the code.
So to do that, we
have the code running.
You can download it or
clone it from GitHub.
I'm going to click on that.
And so on GitHub,
you can either just
copy the URL to
clone it locally,
or you can download
a zip off the code.
I'm going to just clone
that here on my local.
And to do that, I just need
to get clone and the URL,
and that should clone the code.
And I already have it
here for our demo today.
Once you have that,
just one thing
that you need to make sure is
that you have Maven running,
Maven installed.
We're going to use Maven to
run, and to build the project.
OK so you can see I
have Maven installed.
And now when you got
your credentials,
you also got a private key file.
You need to copy a private
key file on the source main
resources directory.
So let me see if I
already have it there.
OK so this is the
sample that we have.
I'm going to copy my private
key, my p12 file into source
main resources, right?
Once I have that, the next
thing that we have to do
is configure the project.
So to do that, we're going to
open the web.xml file, which
is under source main
web app web inf.
And let me open that here.
Source main web app
web inf, web.xml.
In this file, so the first
field we have to change
is the service
account email address.
Change here.
So I have here a cheat
sheet with my credentials,
so I'm just going to copy
that and put it here.
Great.
And then we need to also modify
the path to our private key,
which in this case
then it would be--
do I need to put
web inf classes?
PENG YING: Yes.
MARU AHUES: OK.
PENG YING: That's where it gets
copied to when you build it.
MARU AHUES: OK.
So then yes.
And then from here, I think my
file's called wobs private--
let's see what it was called--
I think it's wobs private key.
Let me see here to make sure.
Wobs private key.p12.
OK.
So that's fine.
Then we also need our issuer ID.
And this is the ID
that you got when
your merchant
account was created.
Let's see.
What's this?
If you don't have an
issuer ID, then you
need to request one through
our Get Access Form.
And once that is
provided to you,
then you can then download
the quick start and try it.
The application name can be
pretty much any application
name.
It doesn't have to match any
of the values that you have
when you created
your credentials.
So I'm just going
put wobs testing.
And those are the four values
that we need to update.
So that's, of course,
defining our documentation.
Once we have that, I'm
just going to save my file.
And we have to
install-- and I'm going
to copy this--
the Wallet Objects
library in our local
Maven repository.
And we're just going
to do that from here.
And make sure that you
are in the root directory
where you downloaded
or cloned the code.
Good.
So that's done.
And after that, all we need
to do then is just run it.
So we're going to run it using
Maven on our local server.
So Maven and App Engine here.
And I'm just going to do that.
And here it's going
to build it first,
and then it's going
to run locally.
So let's see, it's
already running
and it says it's
running on 8080.
PENG YING: There's
two things to note
when you're running
your dev server.
The first thing is that
what Maven likes to do
is encode everything in UTF-8.
So it also encodes
a key sometimes,
which is why we have an
exception rule in the palm.XML.
but if you're getting
an error stating
that some length, the
string length is too long,
then it's likely that your
key is getting UTF-8 encoded.
The second thing is that
Maven sometimes actually
this is more an
App Engine issue,
but what happens
with App Engine is
that the latest version of App
Engine requires the Java 1.7
run time.
So if you're getting
any App Engine errors,
try to install Java
1.7 first, and then
make sure that your
Java home is pointing
to the right directory
for Java 1.7.
You can also check Java
dash version to make sure
that the current
run time is 1.7.
And that should fix
most of the issues
that you're running into.
MARU AHUES: And
that's very important.
When you do run it, make sure
that Java home is exported.
And you can see on
my screen that I just
did that before we
ran the QuickStart.
So we have this running.
We now loaded on our
local instance here
and what do we get?
We get buttons to
insert the classes.
In this case we have a
sample for loyalty and offer.
And once you click on
one of these buttons,
this will insert the class.
And then it will tell me
that the class already
exists because we
already inserted it.
And that's OK.
That's not an error.
Once we have the class inserted,
then we can click on the Save
to Wallet button, and
this will save the object
into my Google Wallet app.
So now if I go into my
Wallet app on my phone,
or if we go into the merchant
dashboard under instances, then
we'll see a preview
of the object
that we saved on our account.
So this is it.
That's all it takes to
download it and run it.
PENG YING: Super simple.
MARU AHUES: Super simple.
PENG YING: Few steps.
MARU AHUES: We hope
you found this helpful.
And if you have any questions
or you want more details
about wallet objects,
go watch our other GDLs.
We do have a GDL about concepts
about Wallet Objects that
should be very helpful as well.
PENG YING: Yeah.
We have an entire series to help
you through the Wallet Objects
integration.
MARU AHUES: Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you next time.